it feels like no time has passed
and loads of times past 20 years after
they first stepped on set they're back
in the wizarding world and all grown up
i think this is the perfect time to sit
down with everyone and reminisce the
harry potter cast and crew were taking a
nostalgic trip down the cobbled memory
lane for an anniversary special it was
rather strange to be back it at least
then to be honest it's been a while and
it's been great seeing everyone it's a
weird experience because you met them as
kids but the author at the helm of it
all is notably absent jk rowling's views
on the transgender community have been
deemed controversial even by former cast
members the story of you know jk rowling
being missing from this reunion is sort
of like the biggest thing about it now
that's what everyone will be watching
this and sort of thinking about as
they're doing that the person who is
missing the fact that none of these
people would be here without her the
fact that we wouldn't be watching it
that harry potter wouldn't exist without
her is a huge absence but for millions
of fans all over the world it's the
reunion they've been desperate to see
you kind of feel like you're a part of
the story with the characters in a way i
mean because you kind of like i'm the
same age as these people i mean like
there's a sense of community because of
like all the houses and it's quite
homely feel to it
it's quite comforting the famous trio
were 10 11 and 12 years old when it all
began despite other productions for
daniel radcliffe activism for emma
watson and fatherhood for rupert grint
the bond remains i wouldn't be the
person i am without so many people here
they grew up not only with each other
but in front of the eyes of the world
it's a very overwhelming thing because
i've watched you grow up and i've seen
kind of every stage of your life it's a
franchise that's not only inspiring
millions but is also continuing to make
millions from a studio tour to a
dedicated theater production to here at
the house of mina lima the graphic
designers behind all of the harry potter
films the wizarding world lives on in
the imagination of so many it's a strong
bond that we'll always have
we're family and we will always be part
of each other's life this reunion means
we can all share in the magic once again
this new year's day ashton harinag sky
news